So, there's been a couple different updates in the Desty case
or whatever the Desty Pixie case,
and I went through the new the response to the motion to dismiss,
and I've not gone through the reply to that response that was
just filed today, but there were some documents filed in the
meantime that I'll address or something, but I'm not going to
do anything else.
So, I'll I'll just explain really quickly and then we'll move
on. Okay.
So, we've got this motion for issuance of letters rogatory. Exhibit
proposed letter of request under heg text of proposed order.
Proposed order. Okay. I don't know why it says proposed order
twice. This is basically Pixie is going to subpoena Molina and
to subpoena somebody in another country. There's like a there's
like some law written in some HEG treaty that you could subpoena
people in other countries through this HEG treaty thing. That's
it. I'm told if you read this, I mean, we could take a quick
look at it. uh pursuant to the head convention of 18 March 1970
on the taking of evidence abroad or civil or commercial matter
or in civil or commercial matters matters.
So you gain the ability to subpoena somebody in another country,
right? That's it. That's all. That's it. That's all.
So here's the thing. You could say Molina would be but there's
another pro there's another possibility here that nobody knows
about as far as I know. nobody would know is
Molina is mostly concerned about getting harassed by Desty's
community. She could say, "Oh, well, file like a subpoena or
something and like come at me legally so I can say no." So, I
could say like, "Okay, I guess I guess I have to." Destiny read
that and thought they were asking the ICC to subpoena Molina.
That's amazing. Yeah, I've heard I've heard the takes on this
are like really really really stupid that this is like some kind
of insane strategy. And I've got a couple lawyers in my Discord
who go over these documents when they get released or yeah, people
I think they're mostly lawyers and they um they look at this
stuff and they're like, "Yeah, this I've I've literally sent
subpoenas this exact way. Like I've used this exact thing to
try to send subpoenas abroad. It also can take a really long
time. You didn't think that he's just a liar?"
>> I'd have to see the clip to know. Why wouldn't she talk
to Molina and make sure Molina is going to testify? I want to
testify before she does this 100% that she's already talked to
Molina.
Why?
It doesn't seem like she's asking Molina to testify. It's just
taking of evidence. I don't even know what this means. Maybe
I guess we'll have to look at the the pursuant order, right,
to see what exactly they're looking for. But this is like um
this is just a form you fill out.
Rose Discord lawyers. Well, lawyers hang out in these communities
and they like talking about this stuff. So, it's it turns out
that
we've got like one of the premier places to do that, the e- rape
defense squad channel.
We've thought about renaming it for Gilmore, but nah, it's it's
fine the way it is. Okay, then there's um well, let's let's look
at the the proposed order
Uh propose propose order granting plaintiff Jane Doe's unopposed
motion for letter of request from for international judicial
assistance to compel discovery from Molina. Oh, hold on, hold
on, hold on. I forgot. There's some stuff in here that we shouldn't
be watching or shouldn't be looking at. beyond Molina's name.
I think like Molina's name is mostly known, but I forgot that
I was given um
I was given some redacted stuff so I don't have to look through
all of that. Give me a second.
This one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right. From Molina.
So,
Torren said in Sweden pursuant to the HEG convention. All right.
Uh, plaintiff Jane Doe by and through the undersigned council
hereby respectfully files this unopposed motion for the issuance
of a letter of request to serve a subpoena to testify and produce
documents on Belina Blank Garansson, a resident of Sweden pursuant
to the HE convention on taking evidence abroad in civil or commercial
matters 23 US 25 whatever.
Uh, plaintiff states as follows. A letter of request, also known
as a letter rogatory roaratory. Rogatory is a document issued
by one court to a foreign court requesting that that foreign
court take evidence from a specific person within the foreign
jurisdiction or serve process on an individual or corporation
within the foreign jurisdiction and two return the testimony
or proof of service for use in a pending case. Letter of request
blacks law dictionary 11. Okay. Letters of request are the means
by which a court in one country requests a court of another country
to assist in the production of evidence located in the foreign
country. Okay, cool. All right, that kind of I mean that makes
sense to me. It's weird that anybody could think it's something
different given this this document existing. See also Federal
Rules of Civil Procedure 28B page 28B
part 28B. No, that's that's procedure. Whoops. Rules of simple
procedure. So permitting federal courts to issue letters of request
to foreign countries.
Okay. Both the issuance and enforcement of letters roatory rogatory
letters rogatory rest entirely upon the committee comedy of courts
towards each other. Comedy.
What is this word?
An association of nations for their mutual
>> Comedy. Cool.
Comedy is the oh recognition which one nation allows within its
territory to the acts of another nation having due regard both
to international duty and convenience and to the persons who
are under the protection of its laws. You're a tad quiet. I'm
not really speaking directly into the mic. I'll be better about
speaking directly into the mic.
So this is like basically nothing in my opinion. Um I don't even
know that this would be So it says it's relying on comedy, right?
So it's entirely possible that they serve Molina and do nothing
outside of that. They just go, "Hey, you've been subpoenaed here."
Right? They might do that, but it might have no power whatsoever.
I don't know. We have no idea. So,
relevant factual back. I mean, this is just going to say I I
think they basically cite authorities for why they can do this.
I know that this is possible. It sounds like this is entirely
like anything you'd have any protections you'd have in Sweden,
you would keep. So, if she doesn't have to testify in like civil
court cases in Sweden or something, it'd be fine. like she she
could ignore this. All right. Uh
let's see. The action involves the non-consentual disclosure
of intimate images under the federal statute commonly known as
Cardi 15 USC 6851 as well as a claim for violation of section
Florida statute for cyber harassment, intentional infliction
of emotional distress and invasion of privacy. More specifically,
plaintiff alleges that multiple times but okay, this is just
restating all the stuff. The need for international discovery.
So argument the need for international discovery. The sought-after
discovery from Molina Gorensson is relevant to the claims in
this action, will likely prove highly material to the prosecution
of this action, lead to admissible relevant evidence, and is
proportional to the needs of this case.
Gransson is the former spouse of the defendant, Steven Kanell,
and is uniquely positioned to provide evidence of the conduct
complained of in the AC in the uh initial complaint, right? AC,
not actual complaint. What would this be? AC something complaint.
[__] now I want to see. It's not initial. Oh, amended
complaint. Amended complaint. I got it. Listen, steel trap up
here in my brain. All right.
As well as similar conduct that she was a witness to by way of
example. Gransen is the recipient of certain explicit materials
involving plaintiff. Gransson is expected to corroborate plaintiff's
allegations, including those allegations regarding Banel's lack
of consent to disclose the video. Moreover, Gransen is or is
believed to be another victim of Banell's unlawful conduct. Finally,
Gransson would testify to Banel's character as it is relevant
to this case. Indeed, Gransen is expressly mentioned in the amended
complaint is relevant witness. Document entry 120 at paragraph
34.
Okay,
so it's saying they cite this for there's some case where granting
plaintiff's motion for a letter of request to in concluding that
the sought-after discovery is relevant to the plaintiff's claims
and may prove material to the prosecution of the action or lead
to material evidence. Okay, so it sounds like there's no reason
that you'd expect the court to deny this. And I'm I'm also expecting
that this probably went through meet and confers and I would
expect Destiny has no plan to like Andrew Brett has no plan to
oppose this. Seems most likely to me, right? Andy B wouldn't
have any reason to want to oppose this. Oh, also also guys, if
you're watching on Twitch, head over to Kick. All right, we're
going to go kick only for the rest of the stream. Love you guys.
Thank you to all the Twitch viewers. Head over to kick
We'll see you there in just a little bit.
Bye-bye. All right. All right. Alternative means of obtaining
the sought-after evidence are unavailable.
Moreover, this evidence cannot be obtained by alternative means
because Garansson's knowledge of the facts relevant to the case
is unique and central to plaintiff's allegations. However, even
if it were available by alternative means for the sake of argument,
the mere fact of an alternative method for obtaining the documents
is not proof that it is necessary uh and effective or efficient
method for doing so. In this case, uh, head convention, balance
of interest among nations. Proposed letter request isn't here.
Okay. Okay. For the foregoing reasons, plaintiff respectfully
requests that the court approve date, sign, and seal proposed
letteratory
to the central authority of Sweden to serve as a subpoena on
Molina Gransson to testify and produce documents in accordance
with the head convention on taking evidence abroad in civil or
commercial matters, which is submitted concurrently herewith,
and for the clerk to authenticate the court's signature by affixing
the court's seal there, too. And that the letter
Wow. Cool,
dude. Is every legal case this dumb? Um,
I don't know. Like, is this dumb? I guess I would need to know
why you think this is dumb. Molina said stuff was shared of her
non-consensually
uh twice now. Both at the Bob seven time and this
said they changed the text after submitting. Oh, wasn't that
Hold on. What is Cyba saying?
That was for another one. They changed the text on a different
motion. Yeah. Is it a different one? Anyway,
none of this seems weird or like wrong to me. So,
yeah. Okay. All right. Cool.
And this was the uh this is the actual letter of request. Okay.
All right. So, that's basically nothing. Let's go back to the
docket. So, that's I think that's the only thing we're not going
to cover. Oh, also the um the original technical expert refiled
or sorry, he amended his uh his filing,
That might be relevant. Maybe it's relevant a little bit later.
I'm not sure. We'll see. What is this? Off topic, but
what is this?
>> I want to I want to kill him. I want to kill this dog
sometime.
>> Christ, dude. >> Yeah. Well,
well, if that's not something you've thought about your your
dog when they're doing something super annoying, I don't know
what to tell you. Obviously, you don't do it. May 27th. Oh, May
27th. So, that's showing the VOD could be from May 27th. Okay,
cool. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Okay, so this is probably
the thing we're going to focus in on today is the reply and support
motion.
This guy's out here today. Let me make sure that this is showing
up well on stream. Oh, it's a little too small. Hold on.
There we go. There we go. There we go. All right. Have a good
night, Cyber. See you later.
Talk was interrupting his stream like a DOS kid.
The dog had taken a blade of grass one too many times. It had
to It had to go. Okay. The dog. It was over for that dog.
Okay. All right. Maximus says, "If anybody's interested in hunting
for that Hassan Vod, you can head over to the Discord. He's going
to be looking in there." Okay.
So
introduction,
this is the just so we're clear there. Desi filed a motion to
dismiss on subject matter jurisdiction grounds. Pixie had a response
and now Desi is following that up. Desi's lawyers with the reply
in support of his motion to dismiss the amended complaint.
All right, so introduction. This court lacks subject matter jurisdiction
over this dispute and plaintiff's opposition offers no evidence
whatsoever to cure that fatal defect. Indeed, in the court's
October 6th, 2025 order denying plaintiff's motion for preliminary
injunction, magistrate judge Torres warned that if plaintiff
cannot show in due course that the conduct alleged is indeed
covered by the statute, it is possible that we do not have subject
matter jurisdiction over plaintiff's case. Plaintiff's opportunity
to establish jurisdiction has come and gone. That's not what
he's saying here.
That's that's the judge saying, "Hey, given that this motion
is filed, it would be inappropriate for me to make a comment
on this. I'm just going to say, hey, this is a possible outlying
issue, and they filed a motion on it.
That's not what they're said. Why? Why go to court and just lie?
The judge knows what the judge knows what he meant when he said
these things. Oh, wait. Hold on. I think this is um this is Jacqueline
Picara would be looking at these ones. So, this one I don't think
this one's remanded to a magistrate judge. This is going to be
a different judge. So, I don't know. This just looks like a lie.
This is just a lie.
But I'm sure the judge will look at it and see that the sorry,
the uh what would she say? the US District Court judge will look
at it and see that the magistrate judge was saying that I'm not
going to rule on this because of this motion and that I'm not
I'm not commenting on the merits of the case. Anyway, the burden
rests on her to establish jurisdiction. Yet, since filing the
complaint in February 2025, plaintiff has failed to produce any
evidence to demonstrate that Benell transmitted the video after
the effective date of the Cardi statute. The record demonstrates
that Benell sent the video on a single occasion to a person named
Rose in April 2022, months before Cardi took effect. Despite
having nearly eight months to conduct discovery, plaintiff has
failed to profer any evidence to the contrary. Notably, in just
the last few weeks, and with the discovery deadline looming,
plaintiff is scrambling to establish subject matter jurisdiction,
engaging in a frantic fishing expedition, including by seeking
relief under the head convention to obtain wholly irrelevant
documents from Banell's ex-wife in Sweden. Plaintiff should have
established subject matter jurisdiction before filing her lawsuit
in federal court. Rather than desperately seeking evidence of
jurisdiction eight months later, having failed to meet her burden,
plaintiff's claims must be dismissed.
Now again,
do you need to have proof
that the crime happened like proof positive that the crime happened
to obtain subject matter jurisdiction would be my question. I
don't know what the burden like the the level of proof required
here is. If it's preponderance of evidence, then I think there
is something where like it's it's getting close. You could make
an argument that there's reason to believe that he did this after
the fact. If it's beyond a reasonable doubt, if you need to know
that for sure, then okay,
>> it is. Well, I assume a civil case is preponderance
of evidence, right? And now basically it comes down to what do
you think is more likely? That Abby hacked this guy's computer,
went through all of his DMs, found like videos that she couldn't
have known existed,
or is it more probable that he sent them? And in that case, I
feel like if you're making that argument, if that's what the
argument comes down to, you have to look at the fact that this
guy's sent a bunch of other people's without their without their
consent, right?
Like Molina said as much, Staceia said as much. There are other
people who have said that this has happened. So again, I think
preponderance of evidence-wise, I think there's every reason
to believe that he sent this video to Abby.
But I don't know that'll I mean, the judge will decide there,
right? It just seems odd to me that you'd argue like it hasn't
been proven beyond a reasonable doubt where you have this person
divining divining um these tapes existence with no evidence like
no um oh sorry dividing these tapes existence with no nobody
saying anything about them that she just made it up perfectly
didn't miss just made it up and got it
>> saying you did it too is nowhere in the filings right
well it's not relevant until you are saying well we believe there's
no evidence evidence of this and it's like well the evidence
is somebody giving testimony you know somebody having contemporaneous
logs that show that this happened
um that show that they were sent this stuff right and then basically
de Destiny's argument is well but and you don't have the logs
me deleting the logs that's actually like you you don't have
any proof right and he's arguing I believe that he doesn't have
to produce his own logs with Abby to show that that like they
would have needed their own side of the logs to to basically
say no we've proven like for a fact that it was sent at this
time. Yeah. So, I don't know. It's pretty interesting. Plaintiff
submits with her opposition a declaration from a purported expert,
Jesus Pena, who falsely appines that Banell has tampered with
evidence in this case. Shockingly, however, Mr. Pena's testimony
is not even his own. He plagiarized his own sworn testimony by
copying and pasting verbatim from a third party's post on Kiwi
Farms, the same website that published the video in November
2024. Worse, Mr. Pena unsuccessfully attempted to conceal this
fact.
Wait, how did he attempt to conceal that
Wait, what?
>> Even if he did copy paste it, why does he have to include
that?
>> This is this is a very interesting argument from from
the side who submitted a bunch of like evidence on their side
that they made up, right, that weren't the the product of any
normal export, any normal evidence, evidentiary procedure to
go to court. And then they that process up and they didn't even
let the court know that they had like made a synthetic thing.
That's that's a crazy argument to be making personally. I just
I feel like that's
bestie said he linked Oh well we'll maybe we'll go through some
of his statements a little bit later. We'll have to see. Then
just two days ago on October 8th, 2025, without even attempting
to meet and confer with Benell's council, plaintiff filed an
untimely motion seeking to amend Mr. Pena's declaration, disavowing
and retracting many of his baseless conclusions of evidence tampering.
The court should disregard the Pena declaration entirely. Oh,
hold on,
hold on. Now, maybe we have to go read that. Right now, I feel
like maybe I got to go read that declaration and see what was
done there, cuz we read it on stream, right? Maybe we got to
go read
exhibit of amended declaration. >> Now I can tell you the
part that he is >> Shut up, Candace. Shut up, Candace.
Shut up, Candace. It has come to my attention that in paragraphs
17 and 18 of my October 3rd, 2025 declaration, docket 1391, I
made a conclusion of tampering based on defendants's incomplete
and faulty document production. These documents were produced
by defendant on September 12th, 2025 in response to plaintiff's
request for documents. Certain of these documents were also submitted
to the court in support of defendants's motion to dismiss. The
issue addressed in paragraph 178 pertained to a Discord direct
message from Rose on April 9th, 2022, 8:33 p.m. Eastern stating
that Rose had viewed the video which defendant did not send her
until 3 minutes later, thus physically not possible. The message
was one of two displayed with a single timestamp of 8:33 p.m.
with the first message acknowledging that Rose would love to
see the video. See supporting images
Yeah.
What occurred is that Rose received the video at 8:36 p.m., viewed
it, and sent Defendant the second message sometime between 8:37
p.m. and 8:39 p.m., and it was timestamped with the correct time.
However, on the Discord viewer and exported HTML messages, the
defendant used Discord chat exporter. Its time stamp by design
was hidden, timestamp grouped, and combined with the first messages
timestamp of 8:33 p.m., which again led to the sign of a of potential
tampering.
The t the time stamp grouping occurs when a user sends multiple
messages. So, he's going to explain this. We we called this out
right away. We just said this is obvious that it's a time stamp
grouping thing that that was like a silly thing to say. It's
important to note that the exported discord messages produced
by defendant in response to plaintiff's document requests, the
ones submitting submitted as exhibits in support of his motion
to dismiss that fell into the category of time stamp grouping
are all missing the child message timestamps key metadata. The
defendant produced a single PDF document with approximately 2400
Bates stamped messages SBO I see. along with attachments but
did so without a standard eiscocovery load file that would contain
the images natives extracted text and metadata that opt which
would have included the child timestamps bait stamping HTML documents
is not a standard eiscocovery workflow when producing documents
thus the defendants council produced a single PDF document from
the HTML version defendant provided to them the chat files are
PDFs created from HTML exports that Mr. Banell sent us for production.
See exhibit one herein. Letter from Andrew Breler to Joan Peters,
Carlos Garcia Perez, September 22nd, 2025. Again, the only issue
is that it stripped the child timestamps from the group messages
and the plaintiff is missing important chron chronology metadata.
The concern now is that plaintiff has failed production which
cannot be relied has of failed production which cannot be relied
upon or remedied and presents an ongoing issue with respect to
further discovery reliant on any data from what the defendant
preserved unless defendant can demonstrate that he generated
a digital fingerprint of the preserved exported messages and
any other preserved ESI electronic
uh something evidence
uh at the time of preservation. The defendant stated in his declaration
paragraph 21 docket 421 that after preserving he deleted the
video and unauthorized published content. Thus any attempt to
go back to the original sources containing said deleted content
would equate to working with spoliated uh data and not reliable.
Moreover, working with the exported preserved data that uh that
was not digitally fingerprinted at the outset cannot be authenticated
and validated because running a cryptographic hash algorithm
would produce a value corresponding to today's date not the date
at which the data was collected. Therefore, there is no way of
determining if the data was altered after the preservation. So,
this is true. This is true. Obviously, I don't know. I've I've
heard Desi disputed this and said hashes are worthless. That
seemed odd to me. Like a very odd thing to say,
but I don't know. We'll we'll go through. We'll see. We'll see
what's up. So, this the amended uh amendment only affects paragraphs
17 and 18 of my original declaration. The remainder is of my
October 3rd, 2025 declaration remains the same. Okay.
Uh that didn't that seemed way less important to me than before.
Why is this untimely by the way? How long do you have to amend
like expert testimony? Oh, my bad. My bad. Ah, that's fair. That's
fair. I'm giddy. Okay, I'm I'm reading. I like reading. All right,
let us continue. Continue. Continue.
Okay. plaintiff has failed to establish subject matter jurisdiction.
Whereas here, a defendant mounts a meritorious factual challenge
to jurisdiction under rule 12b1.
The burden shifts to the plaintiff to establish jurisdiction
by competent proof.
C. Cohan versus Texas Roadhouse Holdings LLC.
Dismissing complaint where plaintiff failed to offer affidavit
or testimony after notice of factual jurisdictional challenge.
Plaintiff must respond to a jurisdictional challenge with admissible
evidence, not speculation to sustain jurisdiction.
I believe the the if I'm not mistaken, the actual what do you
call it? The affidavit, right? I believe that is considered evidence,
right? We'll see.
The response was due today, so they only had like two days to
respond, I guess. Interesting. Yeah. I just I don't understand
the idea that this would not be admissible evidence.
Little strange.
Wee bit strange.
Anyway, we continue. Uh D the non-moving party may not rest merely
upon allegations in the pleadings uh but must set forth facts
showing the court has jurisdiction. So may not merely rest upon
allegations but must set forth upon but must set forth specific
facts showing the court has jurisdiction.
So
I understand how this could be ruled this way.
Um, I don't understand in this case how you would be able to
get this proof without being able to go through discovery, right?
Like the allegation is Destiny shared this stuff and then he
deleted his messages with people before they could file for discovery,
before they could get access to anything on his end. So if he
just deleted this stuff, then the person who is giving them,
you know, this this testimony, he's like, I deleted faster than
anybody could check their DMs, therefore your like whatever you
did doesn't matter. Is that really Can you do that?
Because I guess if you need if you need like the leak in the
same way that the Rose leaks happened. If you need that level
of evidence but within the timeline, then maybe you could say
it can be dismissed. He also deleted them. Well, he's going to
argue that he didn't have to keep it in the original place. But
then I think you're Man, that feels like playing with fire to
me. But it does seem odd that he was able to just delete stuff
from Discord like this.
But again, there are some arguments from the original judge basically
like, "Oh, well, you should be able to delete the video because
you don't want the video to be reaked."
Now, here's what I will say, okay? And I haven't seen Pixie's
team make this argument, but I believe that Destiny did not delete
the videos until November 29th, until they were leaked, despite
being made aware of the compromised account. Now, that to me
would 100% constitute and despite knowing he had sent content
to this person. And so, I don't know if that November, I believe
24th to 29th period could be used as a precedent for, hey, you
waited until these things got leaked publicly to delete them.
How do we know when the export was made from the uh from the
Rose person? Like, what if they hadn't exported everything, hadn't
exported all of the videos? Like, what if we what if we don't
know that anyway? Despite being on a notice on notice of a jurisdictional
defect since the beginning of the case, plaintiff has failed
to submit any evidence of Benell's alleged postcardy transmission
of the video.
A dismissal is warranted pursuant to 12b1. In her opposition,
plaintiff relies on Lawrence v. Dunar
to argue that dismissal under rule 12b1 is precluded because
the jurisdictional facts are intertwined with the merits of plaintiff's
claim.
Yes. So this is this is the thing.
Yeah. I thought this was uh true. So basically like
if this thing exists, this is like the
question being asked in this case is like, hey, I have somebody
alleging this happened right after the time stamp.
Uh I have somebody alleging this happened. They've produced contemporaries
like some evidence of this happening and if this were true, the
case is over. It is like over in Pixie's favor. Like it is totally
intertwined with the merits in this case in my opinion. But maybe
maybe I'm misunderstanding what uh intertwined with the merits
means a plaintiff's claim. They are not. And in any event, Lawrence
expressly holds that federal courts have the inherent authority
to resolve factual challenges to subject matter jurisdiction
under 12b1 unless the factual challenge implicates an element
of the cause of action
ID. Uh so citing this case the date of the trans. So further
the 11th circuit has emphasis added implicates an element of
the cause of action. Oh, they don't say the thing that happened
in Lawrence. Further, the 11th court has declined to make such
determinations where the dispute of fact, eg the date of a transmission
of the video, is merely a threshold question to the applicability
of a federal statute. Yeah, my bad. See, Odyssey Marine uh Exploration
Inc. versus unidentified shipwreck vessel.
How did how did somebody defend uh as unidentified shipwreck
vessel? What are we seeing this?
See Odyssey Marine Exploration, Inc. The unidentified shipwreck
vessel.
What the?
Seems bizarre. Okay. Um although plaintiff contends the motion
to dismiss implicates the merits of the underlying claim that
a lack of subject matter jurisdiction bars a party's claim does
not mean the jurisdictional question in is itself related to
the cause of action. That's not what they're arguing.
uh lack of subject matter jurisdiction bars a party's claim?
That's not what their argument is, right?
I don't think I don't think that's what their argument is. Implicates
the merits of the underlying claim that a lack of subject. So,
they're basically saying that it can't just it can't just be
that because your case will be thrown out unless you can resolve
this like uh if this is unresolved, it doesn't mean that that
itself means it's intertwined with the merits. But I don't think
that's the entire thing here. I think the proof they'd be looking
for that wouldn't just be proof of the time stamp. It would be
proof of the video being sent. It would be literally the thing,
the action, the relevant like element,
>> right? Unless the factual challenge implicates an element
of the cause of action. I think it does, right?
>> I think it does implicate an element of the cause of
action.
>> Does it? Wait, does it not? What? Dude, I need I need
another lawyer here who can use lawyer brain with me.
Okay, cuz it seems like
so one of the elements would be to like disseminate this, right?
It seems like one of the elements would be to disseminate this
video to transmit it in some way and basically you're getting
into whether or not he transmitted it to this specific person.
Yeah, Laticious Gamer, you're who I'm looking for. Okay. Um,
would you not say that this factual challenge? So, they're not
in any of it. Lawrence Lawrence expressly holds that federal
courts have the inherent authority to resolve factual challenges
to subject matter jurisdiction under rule 121 unless the factual
challenge implicates an element of the cause of
>> Would this not?
>> This is uh this is very strange
to me at least. Anyway,
okay. Contends the motion to dismiss implicates the merits of
the underlying claim that a sub lack of subject matter jurisdiction
bars a party's claim. Does not mean the jurisdictional question.
It's is itself related to the cause of
Yeah. But they're they're saying like literally you transmitted
this thing. You are as a part of this claim. This is another
instance of you transmitting this video. Now they could say
what could they say? No, I don't think they could say anything.
if they were trying to say um
this might actually be good evidence though. Unfortunately, this
might be good evidence for why
the resolution of the time stamp for the original video sent
to Rose like the court could rule on that and it would be as
a part of their it would be a part of everything they're doing
to rule on that because with that one that is merely like a threshold
question. it is like, "Oh, does this fall within the uh within
the case timeline or not?" Like the sorry, the law existing,
does it fall within that or not? So, I do think they'd be able
to resolve that and you couldn't say, "Well, that actually the
merits of my case," and it's like, "No, just with whether or
not this is actually like um within our jurisdiction."
Yeah.
Interesting. So, I I don't think this actually works for the
Abby stuff. It would work maybe for the uh the Rose
>> Okay. All right. By the way, I'm not a lawyer. This
is not legal advice. I don't I I'm not trained in this. So, I'm
just giving you my best my best impression here. The date isn't
an element is what he is saying. I'm guessing and Abby should
be disregarded. But Aby's not making the allegation that it's
the date. Abby is making the allegation that the video was disseminated.
That is an element, right? The video was disseminated to her.
If this was only standing up on the date of the time stamp being
like unknown and it could be resolved like 95% by the court,
I think then they could dismiss on the Abby stuff, right? because
there is still a question in the court's eye. They have not ruled
yet whether or not the original transmission to Rose was done
in October or April. And I think if that's the only question,
they could resolve to April and they could say we're dismissing
this case. But with the Abby stuff, I don't think this actually
matters because it does implicate an element of the cause of
action.
So, I think their their actual like citation works against them.
I think anyway we continue because the timing of the April 2022
transmission has no bearing on whether Banell's alleged conduct
meets each element of Cardi Rule 12B1 governs and dismissal is
proper. So I think I think this seems fine uh for arguing with
regards to the Rose thing.
Is Destiny cooked or what? Um
I guess it'll just depend on like a couple things. I don't know
how the court handles certain like dis uh dispute
disputed facts disputation of facts. I don't know how the court
handles disputes. So basically there's somebody who said Desessie
sent them the video. They have logs of them before the videos
were ever public saying oh I was sent this video and Desi saying
well they can't produce logs of me sending them the video. Like
they can't produce the video itself or anything about that so
that's not proof. And it's like, well, you deleted your logs
and the her testimony is the logs were deleted before I looked,
right? So, it's like, could that be like a relevant defense?
Like, she's predicted the existence of these videos
a year before they were ever released.
And then we're going to go, well, but that doesn't count because
um you were at Desty's computer once, I think, is like their
basic argument. >> I don't know
if Destiny's got the same odds of winning as Camala Harris did.
Uh, I don't know about that. Like, I think overall his overall
it's still going to come down to whether or not he sent this
video. I think probably it's going to be quite difficult for
them to convict him or not find him liable if Aby's, you know,
contemporaneous logs are the only piece of evidence. If they
can't get discovery and find additional evidence, I think they
would have a hard time finding him liable in this case.
>> Um, even if jurisdictional facts were intertwined with
the merits, plaintiffs still cannot survive dismissal under a
summary judgement standard. Odyssey Marine 657.
Oh man. Um,
again,
>> I think there is reason to believe that he didn't delete
these videos until November 29th,
>> yeah, I think there's some argument in there that they
they have not made here, but I think they haven't gotten discovery
that they would have wanted yet. So, we'll see. Maybe they have
discovery on all the uh Abbeby stuff. We'll see. Okay, so plaintiffs
still cannot survive a dismissal under a summary judgement standard.
When the jurisdictional basis of a claim is intertwined with
its merits, the court should rule treat a rule 12b1 motion as
one for summary judgement under rule 56. Plaintiff cites no evidence
establishing a genuine dispute of material fact and critically
under rule 56. A non-moving party's failure to submit any evidence
establishing a dispute of material fact warrants summary judgement
and dismissal. I think there are still several disputations of
fact. I think they've they've actually disagreed in a couple
places, right? I think so. We
So, the non-moving party has has failed to establish a genuine
issue of material fact because she has failed to site a single
piece of record evidence in her response. I don't think this
is true.
Yeah, I don't think so. There is no dispute that the transmission
of the video to Rose preceded the effective date of Cardi. The
evidentiary record, including Rose's leaked Discord communications
log conclusively uh communications log conclusively establishes
that the video was transmitted to her in April 2022, nearly 6
months before Cardi took effect. Plaintiff has submitted no evidence
to dispute that fact. Rose's side of her communications with
Benel was accessed and leaked by a third party who being located
in a European time zone is not true, downloaded the messages
such that the time stamps are reflected in European day, month,
year format. I would assume every single Discord exporter could
just let you tweak the the output timestamps. Like there's no
reason to think these things don't just let you format what time
stamp you want on output.
Uh the leaked Discord log shows the message dated 104 2022, meaning
April 10th, 2022. ID or example Banell's own logs confirmed that
the video was sent on April 9th, 2022.
In her opposition, plaintiff submits no evidence to the contrary.
Plaintiff's ever evolving continuous disclosure theory fails
as a matter of law. So this is the other this is another um
this is another point and I would say that
probably oh man this is why I don't know we we have to keep reading
but they should have been making the argument about um him not
deleting the videos immediately. They should have been making
that argument the whole time. In her amended complaint, plaintiff
alleges without any factual or legal basis that Banell transmitted
the video to Rose via Google Drive link and that such a transmission
somehow constituted an ongoing dissemination or continuous disclosure
of the video sufficient to establish subject matter jurisdiction.
Um
about compliance here I I don't know what this is am compliance.
These are some rules that they cite in courts
now that the record affirmatively demonstrates that Benell never
sent the video using Google Drive. see this declaration. Plaintiff
has abruptly modified her theory in her opposition
uh has now abruptly modified her theory. In her opposition, she
now conceds that Banell transmitted the video on one occasion
via Discord in April 2022, but she asserts that even a private
one-time media attachment constitutes a continuous disclosure
under Cardi. Plaintiff's ever evolving theory is entirely unsupported
by law.
Critically, federal courts have repeatedly rejected similar arguments.
In Ray v. Greenberg court held that emailing a public link to
a shared drive to a single of a shared drive link to a single
person where no facts suggest the link was widely disseminated
could not as a matter of law constitute an ongoing uh an ongoing
or public disclosure. The court in the companion case Greenberg
Ray reached the same conclusion. Plaintiff's attempt to rebrand
a single private Discord message as a continuous dissemination
is baseless and should be rejected.
Uh so with this um this is a slightly different case. So the
argument I've seen against this is basically well actually under
Cardi you don't need to do public disclosures. So basically these
were about public disclosures. Cardi is not about public disclosures
explicitly right. It's just if you make it available. So because
Cardi is not about public disclosures. It doesn't have to do
with public disclosures. It's making it available to anybody
or transmitting it to sending it to anybody that that wouldn't
the the standard for the law they're suing under here is about
public disclosures. Right. So they're saying as a matter of like
as a matter of this as a matter of like this case one of the
elements you doing a public disclosure we do not believe this
matches a public disclosure don't posted the screenshots so link
of the yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's the argument they've done
against this
moreover plaintiff's reliance on dovy McCoy is of no consequence
unlike the public postings in McCoy and unknown party butel neither
uploaded nor publicly displayed the video online or in a public
forum nothing in McCoy or unknown party suggests that a private
discord attachment amounts to ongoing disclosure by the original
sender. Indeed, no court has ever held that a onetoone message,
especially one sent before the statute's effective date, constitutes
an ongoing disclosure under section 6851.
Plaintiff fails to submit any evidence that Benel ever transmitted
the video to ABMC. Plaintiff likewise offers no credible evidence
that Banell transmitted the video to ABMC at any time, let alone
evidence that could establish a genuine dispute of material fact
as to such a transmission. Indeed, Banell preserved logs. Banell's
preserved logs show every file sent he sent to ABMC, none of
which contain the video. See this declaration. While plaintiff
nearly alleges Banell transmitted the video to ABMC sometime
after March 2023 via a Google Drive link. The evidence is con
the evidence conclusively establishes such a transmission never
occurred. Uh if you like literally they could have totally fabricated
this evidence and there's no possible way to know that, right?
So, can you So, like let's say if this person were operating
in in bad faith and they were just fabricating this stuff, is
that is there no way for the court to like require something?
Old 10 alert. Destiny crashing out while fixing up his legal
case. Nice semi-relevant cleanser. Well, this is not quite the
same thing. Maximus is not >> not in line with the quote
light criticism, right? And she she's kind of
>> I can't believe you
>> yesterday was like all about this, right? He was all
about his uh time stamps not lining up or whatever. It's not
really fabrication though, Maximus. This is like him being incompetent,
right? It's just him being incompetent in this case.
It's kind of expected, kind of
Banel's communication logs with ABMC demonstrate that only the
only Google Drive links he shared on November 3rd, 2023 contained
videos of another individual, Peach, who has confirmed the content
as her own. Plaintiff's contrary allegation rests on speculation,
not evidence. See, Benell declarations here. Plaintiff's failure
to provide any evidence to support her allegations. Also, hold
on. Um, communication logs with Abby MC demonstrate that the
only Google Drive links were these.
Okay, what if she was just mistaken about it being a Google Drive
link?
would be the first question I'd ask. Blink's failure to produce
any evidence to support her allegations is fatal to her amended
complaint.
This is just not I mean there's evidence there. I don't know.
It seems weird that they just keep repeating the same lie over
and over again. Um also they should respond with uh they should
say I don't know if they get to file any more motions here, but
they should post the Peach logs and say that Peach herself has
said that Destiny has sent her non-conensually recorded material
cuz Peach herself has said that. Yes. So, I guess if we're going
to hold her credible,
then shouldn't we actually subpoena this person, too?
I believe this person's logs should be open for subpoena. No.
And by the way, actually, maybe their whole machine cuz they
they save a lot of stuff. Which year did Peach say that? Uh 2024,
I think.
See, Seven Shocker films this uh non-filling has the non-moving
party has failed to establish a genuine issue of material fact
because she has failed to site a single piece of evidence.
Plaintiff has had nearly 8 months to conduct discovery. Plaintiff's
untimely improper plea for further discovery cannot salvage jurisdiction
and avoid dismissal. Courts deny such fishing expeditions. I
think their their plea for further discovery was because the
preliminary injunction hearing went so long, right? Like it took
so long for that to go by that they asked for more time to do
discovery. I thought this was true. Okay. Course deny such fishing
expeditions where a plaintiff had months to develop the record
yet failed to identify the specific evidence expected to emerge.
See in re Takata airbag.
Um, courts should not reserve ruling on a pending motion to dismiss
in order to allow the plaintiff to look for what she should have
had but did not before coming through the courthouse doors.
Uh, this seems fine, right? But like
I don't know. I I assume they weigh this this specific ruling.
I assume they weigh this against like how convenient is it for
us to dismiss this and then have them find that evidence. Let's
say they find it through some other means and refile or something.
It took that long because Pixie made it that way though. U Yeah,
but it's still a preliminary injunction hearing. Pixie didn't
make it take longer to schedule or have the hearing or like for
them to rule on any of the motions.
It's the Pixie can't make the judge rule faster. The judge took
weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks to rule. Uh it was only a
few weeks ago Pixie filed something asking the judge to hurry
up because they're running out of time. Oh yeah, they they actually
did a motion like, "Hey, can you can you give us a ruling here?
What the [__] going on?"
I see. Stevens be ask is why these initial phase steps are taking
so long. Maybe I'm not totally sure about that. Um I think the
judges whatever the judges seem kind of overloaded. So okay.
All right. Let's keep looking.
Denial for a general request for jurisdictional discovery raised
months after filing the complaint. So they literally said, "Hey,
could you hurry up? We're waiting on this." I thought I thought
there was already a whole conversation about this that had happened
if I'm not mistaken. Plaintiff cannot avoid cannot now avoid
dismissal due to her own lack of diligence. Apart from issuing
a subpoena to Kiwi Farms early on in the case, plaintiff has
done very little in an effort to establish jurisdiction, she
has failed to make take a single deposition or even elicit testimony
from her purported star witness, ABMC.
Um, so I'm guessing Destiny subpoenaed ABMC for like a uh like
a deposition now, right? Cuz he had never in the past he was
mad that he couldn't serve Abby, but he wasn't trying to serve
Abby a deposition request, right? He was trying to serve her
with a a notice to produce documents. So, I assume they'd also
include that they have actually, you know, tried to subpoena
her and ask her questions, right? In fact, plaintiff has obstructed
Banell's access to ABMC despite So, did you try to did you give
them a like a thing that's saying you wanted to ask questions?
I hope so.
Okay. All right. We keep looking. Moreover, given that Banell
has already produced all responsive documents in his possession,
plaintiff has failed to articulate what further discovery she
supposedly still needs. With the discovery deadline looming,
plaintiff is now scrambling in an attempt to establish subject
matter jurisdiction. In just the last few weeks, plaintiff has
begun noticing depositions has begun noticing depositions, retaining
purported experts and even trying to obtain irrelevant materials
from Benell's ex-wife, who now resides in Sweden through the
H convention. Plaintiff's lack of diligence is fatal to her claims.
I mean I there's another there's like another side to this which
would be I assume something like this like hey we need this motion
to go through if um
if if there aren't challenges to Aby's testimony like we have
our subject matter jurisdiction and we can continue this normally.
Oh, they're going to challenge Aby's like subject matter jurisdiction.
Oh, we thought this was in October. We legitimately thought it
might be in October. Oh, we need to go find this stuff now. like
we we have to ask some of these other people that it would have
been very expensive to do. Like I assume trying to subpoena somebody
in Sweden is not cheap. I assume that costs money. So it's like
oh we think we can continue on with their case and then they're
like oh well now now it's taking a long time to go through this
and this is denied or something. So maybe they are scrambling
to some extent but they're probably waiting to make sure they
could go through without having to spend a bunch more money.
Now that might be one of those cases where hey you're a poor
person get loser.
Uh, I believe they have evidence to this fact like pointing towards
this fact. I I think it's insane as well. Like obviously I don't
believe it's uh sent in October, but I think I think they they
felt like they were confused. Now, is that fain ignorance? Maybe.
Unfortunately, that's that's sort of the same level of faint
ignorance where where Destiny goes, "Guys, I just, you know,
I felt really bad that the video's leaked at all. That's why
I said I broke her trust. I violated her trust in the most egregious
way possible cuz like I just felt bad that something totally
expected happened,
right? It's like the same level. I don't know. I have a hard
time feeling like super bad for when when he's done that already,
you know? Uh plaintiff's reliance on Jones v. Waffle House and
Eaton v. Dorchester is misplaced. In each of these cases, the
motion to dismiss was filed at the outset of the case before
the plaintiffs had any meaningful chance to obtain discovery.
These cases do nothing to excuse plaintiffs eight months of
Um, I don't think this is a problem.
>> I don't know. I think I think they'd basically talked
to people about getting an extension on the discovery or to pause
discovery until the motion for preliminary injunction was gone
through.
Anyway, plaintiff's baseless allegation of evidence spoilation
has been repeatedly rejected by the court and the PA declaration
should be stricken. Rather than submit evidence to establish
subject matter jurisdiction, plaintiff instead filed the declaration
from a purported expert who falsely accuses Benell of evidence
tampering. The court has already rejected such contention on
multiple occasions. I think they just said you didn't produce
evidence of this or that you should file a motion for it. I don't
think they reject things that are just allegations. I think they
say show me evidence or shut up.
But I don't know. I I think so. Anyway, order denying motion
to compel. So there's a couple of these deny motions. As Judge
Becca instructed plaintiffs council at the April 4th, 2025 status
conference, the proper channel to seek sanctions for alleged
evidence bulliation is by notice mo motion pursuant to rule 37E
of the federal rules of civil procedure. As the court recently
noted, it is now October of 2025 and there is no such motion
on the docket. Yeah, they don't have evidence of this. They don't
have like um what do you call it?
>> But I don't know like it's like I can't produce evidence
of things you do on your computer, right?
Uh, is it eight months of inactivity or do they overload the
court docket court end docket with way too many motions? >> Um,
maybe.
>> I I still think it's like taking a very long time to
go through. I don't think these motions are like totally Most
of the motions I've seen have not been like
>> Yeah, I just don't think so.
>> Uh, as the court recently noted is not Yeah, sure. We
got that. That plaintiff believes expert testimony is required
to establish subject matter jurisdiction is telling. A party
should not need an expert, even a qualified one, to determine
whether her claims are proper are properly before this court.
>> Why not?
>> Wait, what? Why wouldn't you why would you not want
a technical expert to weigh in on like how things are being done?
>> That seems that seems completely insane, but okay.
Indeed, subject matter jurisdiction is a threshold issue that
should be established conclusively before a plaintiff even files
suit. Regardless, plaintiff's purported expert does nothing to
establish jurisdiction here. In fact, in giving his expert opinion
and accusing Benel of tampering with evidence, Mr. Pñena plagiarized
his sworn testimony. Indeed, he copy and pasted portions of his
expert opinion directly from a third party post on Kiwi Farms,
the very website that published the video online. Okay, he copy
pasted. Okay. Specifically, portions of paragraph 20 of the PA
declaration are copied verbatim from the below post by Code Cave
on Kiwi Farms, which was published on September 20th, 2025, weeks
before Mr. Pena submitted his sworn declaration. Okay.
Google Drive links he says the same he same ones he sent to both
Abby and Peach are actually different. One and two.
>> Okay. This is like this is like saying you plagiarized
some mathematical formula.
These are statements of fact.
that are like not disputed. I would say where's the dis disputation
of any of these statements of fact,
right? I don't know. Like, isn't this embarrassing for a lawyer
to do that? You put 2 plus 2 somewhere on the internet and they
go, "Oh, look, I found a source. I found a source that says 2
plus 2= 4." They they plagiarized that source. They plagiarized
that source.
Okay. I Yeah, I don't understand how this could possibly work
on on somebody after the Keell's manifesto. But
>> but he didn't source it, did he? Why do you have to
source it?
>> Why would you have to source it?
>> Why would you have to s source 2 plus 2 equals 4? I
I don't understand why you'd have to source that. Like these
are these are the actual files. Unless these things are just
like wrong, >> I would say it's like not even a
The argument was that he tried to clean the links but only cleaned
one.
>> No. What the argument was that that was that basically
there's evidence that these things had been changed since their
archival date. That's obviously
Now he he alleged he said this looks like tampering which was
the wrong word to use, right? It's like it's it's tampering or
sorry I think evidence tampering has like an actual connotation.
It's like an actual legal allegation that he can't even make.
But it's like I wouldn't use that cuz it implies something that
I don't think is happening. This is just incompetence in copying.
Telling you his claim today about the Kiwi link. Oh, I see. Okay.
Yeah, sure. Okay. Hold on. Uh Mr. Pas submitted this worse. While
Mr. Pena attempted to conceal his actions by removing the hyperlink
destination on one of the embedded images in his declaration.
He failed to take the same measures for the plagiarized embedded
image on page 13 of his declaration which still contains the
hyperlink destination to the Kiwi Farms Post. See Henderson v
Lheed Martin. Okay. I do you have to maybe you have to source
these things. Maybe holding that plagiarism in experts reported
warranted exclusion of expert holding that plagiarism in experts
report warranted exclusion of expert who passed off others work
as his own demonstrating an unreliable methodology as a whole.
So would this be we could look at this okay Henderson v Lockhead
Martin Corp.
Um would this be like an opinion overall that he would plagiarize
or is it just the evidence the factual evidence that he copy
pasted from here? He copi pasted after
I don't know. How do you remove a hyperlink from an image? I'm
guessing embedded in the PDF file there's a hyperlink to Kiwi
Farms to show the image
where in one of the cases he would have used like a third party
thing or in another case he would have left the hyperlink to
Kiwi Farms in the document.
yeah, but I would say leaving the hyperlink in there isn't really
proof he was trying to mislead or plagiarize.
I don't know.
It's federal law that you're not allowed to site the farms. Well,
that's crazy, man. I don't I don't think that's true. I don't
think that is a federal law. Call me crazy. I don't think that's
a federal law. Okay.
Moreover, just two days ago on October 8th, 2025, plaintiff filed
an untimely motion without even attempting to meet and confer
with Benell's first council first seeking to amend the Pena declaration
wherein she informed the court that paragraphs 17 and 18 of the
declaration were no longer supported.
ECF number 147. Mr. Pñena submitted an amended declaration disavowing
and retracting certain meritless conclusions of evidence spoilation
particularly as it pertained to transmission of the video to
Rose. The Pñena declaration must be stricken and disregarded
accordingly.
Um, no. He said basically like I I looked at this and there's
no trail. So there is information that would be required missing
here because of the the
uh I guess you would say the technique he used to preserve evidence.
There are things that are missing that are important, but I do
believe that like
this wasn't um this isn't proof of like expoliation, which I
didn't think I didn't think it was proof of expuliation either.
So, all right. Conclusion. For these reasons, the reason set
forth in Banell's motion, Banell respectfully requests that the
motion to dismiss be granted in its entirety.
I guess we'll see here because I don't know. Does Pixie get another
opportunity to respond? I think this is like where you're going
to see if this goes through. Now, nobody thought this was going
to go through.
Um,
I guess you'd have to ask, you know, some lawyer on how like
about how strongly they can rely on witness
right? Because I feel like the Abbeby stuff is going to be allowed,
but that's based on me seeing other lawyers talk about this.
Objection. You're snarking.
All right. So, that's the whole thing here. I I guess maybe the
lawyer is saying that the dude just look at the kiwi farms without
doing his own process that reached the same conclusion. So, we
don't know if it's his pro opinion. So, how can we take this
seriously?
Um, but what did he what did he take from here? Right? It looks
like he took these images to show the differences,
It look like it looks like that's what he did. He just took these
images to show the differences. In my opinion, that doesn't mean
that that it's like
And most of his uh what would you call it? Most of his like expert
testimony is pertaining to other different things.
Like this is a very small part of his testimony. Yeah, I'll probably
take a look. R I'll probably take a a look. Noticing the logs
being different isn't a professional opinion. Yeah, this is like
something anybody could do. You don't have to be a professional
to to see a difference between these things.
Anyway. Oh yeah, you definitely don't have to be a professional
to see the difference. Like L1. Yeah. Okay.